so we always talk about single life
relationship right you know I always
bring up the topics but you've been
married since you're 17 and so we wanna
maybe just do a video today
marriage is up 17 and with the same
girls I'm 16 yes sounds like marriage to
me anyway so so like I was saying we
want to know what are you some of your
tips for making marriage or at least
your marriage works like if I had to
give you one thing mmm ladies shut the
[ __ ] up sometimes you need to shut the
[ __ ] up I'm married now and my number
one advice for like a healthy marriage
is like developing your shut the [ __ ] up
filter ha ha like there's so many times
that I always want to voice my opinion
or say how I would do things or give an
alternate route but if I just be quiet
one sometimes it actually pans out even
better than I thought it would
or number two it's like let that person
have the joy of having their vision come
to fruition just like you want to assert
your vision this moment like they also
want that same feeling of knowing they
did it their way shut the [ __ ] up - shut
the [ __ ] up - sometimes it's good to
shut the [ __ ] up and when you see and
when you actually learn to shut the [ __ ]
up it will last longer like if you would
just shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
it's not about it's not even a bad thing
people are gonna think of it's a bad
thing like oh you're talking yes shut
the [ __ ] up
I would love dinner like that no one
gives a [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up okay
Fergie shut up just shut up shut up
sometimes that's what it is and you know
what I'm gonna tell you one thing I'm
gonna tell you one thing like I deal
with a lot of [ __ ] my girl sometimes
she's like yo you you don't have a
problem with a lot of things that we do
like I said when I I said I don't want
to go to Mexico you you like it let's
see I would've told you we wanna go I
want to go to Greece I'd be like yeah
sure I'm a yes shirt kind of guy why
it's not that bad I'm here we're still
gonna have a good time no matter what
happens doesn't happen where we
what happened is this mean that person
so it doesn't matter all right I know
you could be pleasantly surprised
because yes my girls like yo it's like
you're not interested at first back in
the days I'm like no it's just that it's
cool it's not it's not that important
what you mean it's not important shut
the [ __ ] up and let's just go cuz it's
not you try to make it a thing and it's
not a thing right now you want to go
there sure you don't look interested I
said sure well you know you should look
so entrance let's go we're going I said
sure even with my friend sometimes I'm
like I'm like okay but what are we
arguing about
but what is this about about it because
I feel like this it's not even like it's
okay you're making this out of it
it's not that so we're not arguing
what's the problem if that's not a
problem
shut the [ __ ] up can I just say
something when you your advice don't you
know the one you said earlier shut the
[ __ ] up that one yes almost all of my
dating experiences the women I've been
with have always been like AB I feel so
comfortable with you it just feels like
you're a great listener and that you
give me space to be myself and I'm like
yeah that's probably because I shut the
[ __ ] up and events that that's the thing
and that's the thing you can you know
what you said about tolerance levels
yeah hi you Tara's level is pretty high
I gotta admit people will say yeah but
you don't open up it will come
eventually if you shut the [ __ ] up
enough yeah being pressured into opening
up doesn't make me one open no so let
that happen
alright I got 10 more pieces of marriage
advice I want to give you guys so advice
number one shut the [ __ ] number two know
your P's and shut the [ __ ] up
number vice number three don't pressure
nobody to open up and shut the [ __ ] up
about that advice number four shut the
[ __ ] up Paul you're really gonna shut
the [ __ ] up go on no I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] up
[Music]
quick announcement we're gonna be
starting up quite a few changes for the
new year
this Friday we're gonna be doing a live
stream here on YouTube where we're gonna
be discussing some of the videos that we
did this week as well some of your
comments so if you want to leave some
feedback if you want to yell at us
that's your place to do it
so be sure to check in for that as well
in the new year we're gonna be switching
things up because we all want to
diversify our income but we also want to
make more projects we're gonna be really
pushing our patreon what that means is
that we're going to have a live podcast
that is going to be exclusive to our
patreon people if you suggest topics
give us questions there's going to be
tears that are gonna be set up in order
to reward you for the fact that you want
to have your input put into the channel
so be sure to check that out we're also
gonna have exclusive clips that we put
out once a week on the patreon so if you
want extra content if you want to
support us and really help us to do this
full-time then that's a way you can do
it